Kurt Russell and Academy Award winner
Goldie Hawn
before we go any further here Tom Cruise
and Barry Levinson we gotta let you know
that your buddy Dustin's going crazy
backstage because he didn't have time to
thank you so he thanks you now honey I
was just thinking back there that we fit
in completely to the theme of the show
because we're co-stars we're compadres
we're companions and we're a couple
there's only one thing we're not what
married is that a proposal
put me on the spot I guess now's as good
a time as any to answer that I oh he
want us to speed things up listen we'll
talk about it later tonight okay
the role of a director needs no
explanation
real dog about these fill my place
you'll see why we'll be back in a minute
and the nominees are
Charles Crichton the veteran comedy
director his fresh catch was a Fish
Called Wanda Martin Scorsese who
triumphed over insurmountable obstacles
realizing his personal vision of the
last citation of price Alan Parker who
shone his light on the dark chapter in
American race relations in Mississippi
Burning Barry Levinson who examined
autism brotherly love and a new way to
beat the house at Caesar's Palace and
Rain Man
and mike nichols who believe me can give
dictation with the best of them for
working girls and the Oscar goes to
Barry Levinson
thank you this is a really about two
actors Tom Cruise and Dustin Hoffman if
they don't deliver and the performances
that they gave I wouldn't be up here
this evening I have to tell you I'm
Symes I'm so uh I'm so sure couples I'm
so taken by the response to Rain Man and
that we've had such a positive effect on
the audience's that have seen the movie
I'm really appreciative I thank all you
people in the Academy we have a
wonderful staff that did a lot of work
on autism we tried to be as faithful as
we could in the same time try to be
entertaining I I have to thank Michael
Ovitz who worked to keep this movie
alive when we were in a lot of times
when it may not have ever happened and I
have to thank my wife Diana who when I
walked into the bedroom when I said I
can do Rain Man and she was seven months
pregnant I said what do what do you want
to do and she said let's go on the road
and do the movie have the baby wherever
we were traveling to we had a little
baby boy and I thank her for that and I
thank you for this
the first I knew Academy
we'll be back with Dustin Hoffman and
Tom Cruise and an award for Actress in a
leading role